ونحييكم من جديد تلقى الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي اتصالا هاتفيا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
الاتصال تناول عمليه العوجه التي شهدتها
الخطوط المصريه الاسرائيليه السبت والتي
اودت بحياتي ثلاث جنود اسرائيليين وخلال
الاتصال اكد الجانبان اهميه التنسيق بشكل
كامل لكشف جميع ملابسات العمليه بالاضافه
الى عزمهما الاستمرار والتنسيق في سياق
العلاقه الثنائيه والصعير لتحقيق السلام
العادل الاعلان عن الحادثه جاء من اسرائيل
اولا صباح السبت بعد عثورها على جثتي
جنديين اسرائيليين قتل بالرصاص عند نقطه
حراسه قرب قاعده حريق العسكريه على بعد
100 كيلومتر من جنوب قطاع غزه قرب الحدود
مع مصر لاحقا اطلق الجيش عمليه مطارده
بحثا عن المنفذ الذي عثر عليه ظهرا في
المنطقه ذاتها قبل ان تجري عمليه
لاطلاق النار قتل خلالها جندي اسرائيلي
ثالث فيما اصيب جنسيون رابع بجروحه فيما
كانت روايه مصريه بان احد عناصر الامن
المكلفه بتامين خط الحدود الدوليه قام
بمطارده عناصر تهريب للمخدرات واثناء
المطارده قام فرض الامن باختراق حاجز
التامين وتبادل اطلاق النار مما ادى الى
وفاه ثلاثه من الجنود الاسرائيليين واصابه
اثنين اخرين بالاضافه الى وفاه فرض
التامين المصري اثناء تبادل اطلاق النار
معبر العوجه نيتسان الحدودي بين اسرائيل
ومصر انشئ عام
1982 عقب معاهده السلام بين اسرائيل ومصر
على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا من نقطه التقاء
الحدود الاسرائيليه المصريه شرق رفح
استخدم في بدايته معبر للمسافرين
والمركبات يستخدم حاليا لاستيراد البضائع
من مصر الى اسرائيل او قطاع غزه عام 2012
بنى اسرائيل سياجا امنيا على طول الحدود
بطول 241
كيلومترابا على البحر الاحمر حتى نقطه
التقاء الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
نوفمبر 2022 تاريخ اخر محاولات تسلل
شهدتها الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه قتل
خلالها احد المهربين
من القاهره دكتور محمد مجاهد ايات مستشار
المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك من القدس
المحلله السياسي اهلا بكم سابدا من
القاهره معك دكتور زياد دكتور زياد بدايه
الملفت اننا امام معلومات
وسياقات متضاربه ومتباينه ومتناقضه احيانا
ما تفسير ذلك
يعني هو مش متناقضه بصوره كامله يعني
المعلومات سواء من جانب الاسرائيلي او
الجانب المصري تتحدث عن تجاوز احد افراد
الامن المصريين للحدود ما بين اسرائيل
وبين مصر
ومقتل
جنود اسرائيليين ومقتل فرد الامن الذي
تجاوز الحدود الحديث في الروايه المصريه
حتى هذه اللحظه انه كان يطارد مهربين
مخدرات لان هذه الاعمال منطقه شهدت عمليات
تهريب مخدرات بصوره كبيره ولم تنتهي
التحقيقات حتى الان
الاتصال التليفون الذي تم ما بين الرئيس
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي والرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي تحدثت عن
التفاهم او تنسيق فيما يتعلق بكشف جميع
الجوانب الخاصه بالعمليه فلم تتضح معلمه
حتى الان لكن الواقع او الواقعه كلها
اتفقت عليها المصدرين في عمليه مقتل
الجنود الاسرائيليين ومقتل الجند المصري
نحن في انتظار
لجنه التحقيق المشتركه التي لا شك انها
ستتوصل الى نفس الاستنتاج الذي
اشير اليه اسرائيليا وهو بان العنصر
المصري دخل بدون اي مبرر الى داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه قام بفعلته بقتل الجنديين
الاسرائيليين في المرحله الاولى ومن ثم
توغل الى داخل الاراضي الاسرائيليه الى
بعد كيلو متر ونصف الكيلومتر واشتبك مع
القوات الاسرائيليه للمره الثانيه وهذا
مما ادى الى اصابه والى اصابه احد الجنود
ومقصد اخر
يعني لم لم يكن لم يكن يلاحق مهرب بمخدرات
سيدتي هذه هي ليست المهمه التي اوتيل بها
حسب المعلومات
الاشتباك مع
المهربين المخدرات كان في الساعه الثانيه
والنصف من الليل بعد منتصف الليل
اجتازه الحدود حسب حسب التخفينات
الاسرائيليه في الساعه السادسه صباحا
اغتال الجنديين في الساعه السادسه تقريبا
الاشتباك الثاني مع القوات الاسرائيليه
داخل الاراضي كان في حوالي الساعه الحاديه
عشره قبل الظهر اي انه اولا لم يكن مخولا
بالدخول الى الاراضي الايطاليه ثم قام
بمقام به بان فعلته بصوره متعمده ربما
بدون حسب تحقيقات لسيري بان الليل قام
بمفرده بدون اوامر بدون
ان تكون منظمه
الاسلاميه متشدده من ورايا قامت بسبب
ميوله الشخصيه بما قام به اجتاز الحدود
الايطاليه عبر بوابه
وهو وهذا هذه هي التفاصيل على كل اسرائيل
تنتظره اللجنه التحقيق المشتركه تنتظر
ايضا لتحقيقات التي ستجري في الجانب
المصري وايضا لوضع الترتيبات الجديده
واعود للحديث عن هذه الترتيبات وسنعود
للحديث عن هذا الترتيبات ولكن دكتور زياد
في كل الحالات نحن نتحدث على عمليه اختراق
امني من يتحمل مسؤوليه فشل تامين الحضور
من الجهه الاسرائيليه او من الجهه المصريه
من يتحمل هذه المسؤوليه مصر او اسرائيل
يعني هو تامين الحدود مرتبط بمسؤوليه
البلدين لكن هناك جزء في اتفاقيه السلام
الموقعه ومعادله السلام ما بين مصر
واسرائيل تحدد عدد القوات المصريه
الموجوده في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد بناء
قوات شرطه وبالتالي قوات الشرطه اضعف من
قوات الجيش حتى من الناحيه الثانيه ايضا
المنطقه التي داخل الاراضي الاسرائيليه
محدد الوجود العسكري فيها
والتخفيف الوجود العسكري في الناحيتين
ربما يكون فقط حضرتك تتحدث عن ما اتفق
عليه بعد كم صحيح التقسيم المناطق الى
اربعه مناطق اي بي سي دي بحضور شرطي
وبحضور كذلك ولكن يقال بانه بعد 2018
تغيرت بعض الترتيبات التي لا تتفق مع
اتفاق كم ديفيد
هناك اتفاق حصل بين الحكومه المصريه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه في اطار مواجهه
الحكومه المصريه لعمليات الارهابيه ونشاط
التنظيمات العسكريه الارهابيه في سيناء
وتم الاتفاق على دعم القوات المصريه
وتسليحها في المناطق غالبا كانت في الشمال
بصوره اساسيه وليست المناطق وسط سيناء
لوجود العسكري المخففون او لعل الاجراءات
التي اتخذت فورا الحادثه في الامس
بالتحديد بان تكون هناك دوريه متحركه
بالاضافه للوجود العسكري الشرطي لتامين
الحدود بصوره اكبر واعتقد ان سيكون هناك
تامين اكثر من حدود الاسرائيليه انك
مناقشات او تحقيقات اسرائيليه تجري كما
اوضح المصادر الاعلام الاسرائيليه بان
هناك نقاط ضعف يجب ان تعالج لضمان يعني
يكون هناك نوع من السيطره تكررت عمليات
التهريب المخدرات في المنطقه سابقا
هل يمكن في هذا الاطار القول بان اسرائيل
حريصه ولا زالت على مثلا حدودها مع جنوب
لبنان على حدودها مع قطاع غزه ولكن وكانه
بعض المواضيع خفضت من تامين حدودها على
مستوى مثلا معبر العوجه هل تتحمل اسرائيل
ما حدث
تنظر الى الحدود مع مصر حدود سلم ربما
هناك تفسير كما ثبت في العمليه يوم السبت
بان هناك تفسير من قبل الاجراءات الامنيه
من قبل
التصرف الوحدات العسكريه ومن قبل
التمثيبات الامنيه الجاريه في المنتصف
ولكن منطقه الحدود مع مصر كان منطقه سلم
هي في نظر اسرائيل
تختلف تماما عما عن التعامل مع الحدود مع
لبنان او مع سوريا ولذلك حدود سلمه بتختلف
تماما مع حدود مواجهه
تنظر الى طالما حضرتك تعتبر بان اسرائيل
تعتبر حدودها مع مصر حدود سالم هل هذه
الحادثه او هذه العمليه ستغير المعادله
الاساسيه او ستغير حسابات اسرائيل بحسب
اعتقادك
رئيس الوزاره والرئيس السيسي بين وزيره
الدفاع للكلى البلدين بين رئيسين
الهيئات الاركان للكلى البلدين وايضا بين
قاده الالويه والوحدات العسكريه بان
الطرفيه الحدود خلال الاربعه ايام الاخيره
التوقعات الاسرائيليه هو النظر في اعاده
انتشار
القوات المصريه على امتداد الحدود ايضا
النظر في الوسائل الامنيه لضمان عدم تكرار
مثل هذه الحوادث سؤال رئيسي في الواقع
الذي يطرح في داخل الاسرائيلي ما قراناه
من تعليقات الاسرائيليين كيف يمكن ضمان
عدم تكرار مثل هكذا حادثه الدكتور زيات من
الجانب المصري هل يمكن نعلم بانه معاهده
كام ديفيد قائمه ومستمرين فيها ولكن ما
الذي يمكن ان يتغير بعد عمليه العوجه
دعيني اشير في البدايه الى ان مصر حريصه
على ان تكون العلاقات مع اسرائيل طبقا
لمعاهده السلام وحريصه على ان تبقى تلك
الحدود ما بين البلدين حدود امنه لانها
يعني التامين الحدود مطلب مصري في ظل ما
واجهته مصر من تهديدات على امتداد الحدود
في الشمال انا في اعتقادي ان الفتره
القادمه ستشهد تكثيفا امنيا مصريه في تلك
المنطقه ووسائل جديده لضمان عدم اختراق
الحدود ووقف كل ليس فقط عدم اختراق الحدود
او القيام بعمليات تعرضيه ولكن كذلك لمنع
عمليات تهريب المخدرات او تسلل للافراد او
الهجره غير المشروعه لان تلك المنطقه
منطقه صعبه جغرافيا في وسط سيناء مناطق
فيها جبال وفيها كهوف وبالتالي تحتاج الى
نوع من التامين الاكثر اكثر تطورا لضمان
تامين تلك الحدود سيدي لماذا لا يتفاهم
بعض الاسرائيليين بانه ما حدث هو
عمليه منفرده تتعدى الجيش المصري الدوله
المصريه هناك من يؤخذ سلطات في داخل
المصري على هكذا عمليه ويحملها المسؤوليه
ما تفسير ذلك
لاي عنصر السلبي قاضيه ميسي العلاقات
الاسرائيليه المصريه التي مضى عليها 43
سنه لا يمكن ولا نولي لهم اي اهميه وايضا
سواء وسائل الاعلام او السلطات
الاسرائيليه السياسيه والامنيه لذلك كل
هذه الاصوات هي ليس لها غير مهمه غير
مسؤوله وهي هامشيه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ولا يسمع لها صوت بل من يحاول الاستماع
اليها هو من يحاول التعبير سفر العلاقات
الاسرائيليه المصريه
فقط لا غير ولذلك لو سمحتي بس اعود مره
ثانيه الى الموضوع واستكمالا لما ذكره
الدكتور فقول انه بالاضافه
بالاضافه الى الاجراءات المتطلبه التي من
المقرر ومن المتوقع من الجانب المصري ان
يتخذها هو تنقيه او عدم
تمركز عناصر من الجيش المصري او الشرطه
المصريه ده على امتداد الحدود الاسرائيليه
والتي معروف معروفين بمريولهم او بمواقفهم
المتشدده
دينيا اسلاميا او ارهابيا او طيب ولكن
فقط لكم مطالب للجهه المصريه لك تعليق
دكتور زياد باختصار ان سمحت تفضل
نعم يعني هو الحديث عند انتظاركوز عناصر
ارهابيه ده امر يعني غير غير موجود ولا
توجد عناصر الارهابيه موجوده والذي قام
بالعباد العمليه محمد صلاح الذي الذي قام
بها تحقيقات حتى الان لم تثبت انه او اي
من اسرته له مواقف متجدده بهذا الشكل
واضح سيد شلومه اوضح ضيفه الفكره واعتقد
بانه بانك اسقطت سهوا هذه الكلمه سيد شوم
ونزلت معنا تسمعني
من حضرتك بانه سقطت سهوا هذه الكلمه لانه
قراناها وفيما بعد
هناك تراجع على طرح هذه الكلمه ولكن ساختم
معك باختصار
منذ قليل كانت لك مطالب للجانب المصري بان
يتم توزيع القوات سواء الجيش او الشرطه
بطريقه معينه ولكن السؤال مطروح اين
اسرائيل بعد هذه العمليه لانه الجنط الذي
نتحدث عنه مشى على مسافه خمس كيلومترات
فيما بعد اجتازه حاجز امني فيما بعد وصل
الى سكنه التي يتواجد فيها جنون
الاسرائيليين ثم بعد توجه الى العمق
الاسرائيلي واختبا حتى ساعه 9:00 صباحا
اين القوات الاسرائيليه في كل هذا
لا شك ان هناك تبصير اسرائيلي وعلى اثر
هذا الحادث تم تشكيل عده لجان عسكريه تقوم
بتحقيق بصوره مستعجله وستقدم في مطلع
الاسبوع القادم توصيتها الهيئه رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه وايضا اللجنه التحقيق اخرى
كلفت بالنسبه
لمناقشه التعامل المطلوب في حدود السلم اي
مع الاردن ومع مصر وايضا لجنه تحقيق اخرى
داخل الكتيبه وداخل الالويه التي المرابطه
في هذا المكان كيف تصرفت وكيف تعمل اي
هناك عده لجان عمل تحقيق الداخليه
اسرائيليه عسكريه هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى
اللجنه التحقيق المشتركه الاسرائيليه
المصريه التي سترفع ان شاء الله توصيتها
ايضا في في بدايه الاسبوع القادم وهذا
وفقا للاتفاق ليس في المستويات الواطيه بل
ايضا كما تم الاتفاق عليه بين الرئيس
السيسي والرئيس الوزراء نساديه وضحت
الفكره هل يمكن ان يكون هناك اعاده ترتيب
لتمركز هذه القوات
سنتابع هذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا لكم من
القاهره دكتور محمد المشاهد ازيات مستشار
المركز المصري للفكره والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن القدس المحلله السياسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات